bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'en quête d'europe
au menu de cette émission quatre
reportages tournés aux quatre coins de
l'europe par nos équipes de reporters
sur lesquels nous avons souhaité revenir
faut-il s'inquiéter de la surmortalité
des abeilles la moldavie est elle peu à
peu en train d'intégrer l'europe et
comment l'allemagne compte sortir du
nucléaire voici le reportage que nous
allons revoir mais d'abord on part à la
frontière gréco turque avec thomas
raguet point de passage de l'immigration
clandestine en europe
alors thomas au moment où l'europe se
déchire à cause des arrivées massives de
migrants tunisiens et libyens à
lampedusa vous vous avez choisi de vous
rendre à la frontière gréco turque pour
quelles raisons et mais la grèce
jusqu'il ya très peu de temps était la
première porte d'entrée en europe pour
les migrants et donc par conséquent on a
plus de recul dans cette région on peut
voir comment s'est organisée
l'administration grecque la police
grecque et l'union européenne pour
essayer de juguler ce transit de
migrants
les migrants qui viennent
essentiellement non d'asie c'est l'asie
centrale pour la cohorte on regarde
votre partager mon sens parlant suite
des images nocturnes de chasse à l'homme
diffusées sur le web
nous sommes à la frontière gréco-turque
un des principaux points de passage de
migrants en quête d'europe
d'après les autorités grecques trente
six mille arrestations ont eu lieu ici
en 2010 une situation qui a conduit la
grèce à faire appel à la frontex la
police européenne aux frontières
l'objectif principal est de renforcer la
surveillance d'une bande de terre d'une
douzaine de kilomètres où la rivière
evros ne fait plus office de frontière
depuis la ville turque d'edirne 10
minutes de marche suffisent pour rentrer
en grèce depuis novembre dernier 300
policiers européens sous commandement
grec patrouilles dans la zone
je suis venu ici avec ma voiture de
patrouille roumaine mon travail consiste
à surveiller la frontière
nous ne pouvons pas prendre de décision
nous mêmes nous sommes uniquement là
pour aider la police grecque
à terme les autorités grecques projette
d'installer une clôture barbelée équipés
de caméras pour empêcher les passages en
attendant elle compte sur la frontex
dont la mission devrait durer au moins
jusqu'à la fin 2011
selon le chef de la police locale
son impact est évident en octobre nous
avons eu environ six mille arrestations
avant que l'opération ne débute
mais en février nous n'en avions plus
que cinq sens et cette baisse a continué
jusqu'à maintenant mais nous avons
constaté une augmentation des passages
par la rivière c'est un côté mais cela
giorgio salama casse le reconnaît la
présence de la frontex a eu pour
conséquence un déplacement des flux
migratoires vers le sud
un aveu d'impuissance en somme la police
grecque manque de moyens et se retrouve
incapable de contrôler entièrement une
frontière longue de 150 km de rivière ni
d'accueillir correctement un tel flux de
population
une fois arrêtés les migrants sont
dirigés vers des centres de rétention
comme celui ci à la sortie du village de
filakio impossible de filmer à
l'intérieur la police grecque évoque des
raisons de sécurité il faut dire qu'au
mois de décembre 2010 une émeute a eu
lieu ici une révolte prévisible qu'à
prévu à l'origine pour cent personnes le
centre accueille aujourd'hui près de 400
hommes femmes et enfants dans des
conditions d'hygiène déplorables
ce jour là quelques migrants sont
relâchés essentiellement des afghans et
des somaliens
ils ont tous en main un précieux sésame
ces papiers dit nous devons rester 30
jours avant de quitter un territoire
pour l'europe par exemple
et quel est votre projet je voulais
d'abord quitter l'afghanistan
maintenant j'aimerais aller en europe il
y avait trop de problèmes en afghanistan
de travailler avec les américains comme
interprète
je devais quitter les médis temps les
deux en danger oui quand est-ce que vous
avez traversé la frontière
avant-hier vous avez fait
faites nous avons nagé nous étions
poursuivis par la police turque donc on
a dû aller dans l'eau trois des nôtres
sont morts noyés
c'était un moment vraiment horrible
bonne chance merci à eux ne sont restés
que deux jours captif en provenance de
pays en guerre ils ne sont pas
expulsables et sont donc rapidement
libérés d'autres à l'intérieur sont
moins chanceux algérien nigérians ils
peuvent rester jusqu'à six mois enfermés
une fois dehors faut-il encore avoir de
l'argent 60 euros l'aller simple vers
athènes les billets sont vendus à la
sortie et le chauffeur vient même faire
l'embarquement sur place ceux qui n'ont
pas d'argent sont dans l'impasse les
gens à l'intérieur n'ont pas d'argent et
personne pour leur en envoyer
il arrive que les gens se fassent voler
par d'autres prisonniers ils ont besoin
d'argent et tous les moyens sont bons
pour en trouver
l'ambiance est très agressive
c'est vraiment sale il est très facile
de tomber malade
voilà c'est tout merci des conditions
sanitaires déplorables dénoncée par le
conseil de l'europe au mois de mars
dernier et encore filakio et le plus
présentable des centres
la plupart des lieux de détention sont
d'anciens postes de police reconverti
aux fenêtres murées au toit grillagée
comme celui-ci des lieux que la police
grecque cash aux yeux des journalistes
à l'heure où la grèce traverse l'une des
pires crises économiques de son histoire
l'amélioration des conditions d'accueil
des migrants est loin d'être une
priorité
l'union européenne a donc décidé de
mettre la main à la poche
217 millions d'euros sur trois ans cette
aide n'est pas pour financer la
construction du fameux mur il s'agit de
lave de l'amélioration des centres
d'accueil et d'amélioration des
infrastructures de l'aide aux réfugiés
même y compris pour une partie
la financement de l'effort pour le
rapatriement volontaire depuis quelques
mois les autorités grecques observe avec
attention la situation en italie un
appel d'air à lampedusa
c'est autant de migrants qu'ils ne
tenteront pas d'entrer en europe par la
grèce un répit mais jusqu'à quand en
attendant les candidats au départ sont
toujours aussi nombreux alors thomas
vous avez longuement suivi la frontex
dans votre reportage cette agence
européenne chargée de surveiller les
frontières
est-ce que ce dispositif est efficace ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça soulage la
police grecque qui disposent de peu
d'hommes et peu de moyens les policiers
européens sont venus avec leur voiture
avec beaucoup de matériel et donc ça a
aidé beaucoup travail de surveillance de
cette frontière
maintenant est-ce que ça a eu un impact
sur la une baisse du nombre de passages
de cette frontière par les migrants ça
il est un peu trop tôt pour le dire il
faut attendre très certainement la fin
de l'année pour comparer les chiffres de
l'été 2011 avec celui de l'été 2010 qui
était très important à l'époque il y
avait près de 400 passages quotidiens de
migrants c'était une qui est lent d'un
village qui passaient chaque jour de
turquie en grèce alors autre chose vous
avez filmé des centres de rétention qui
sont pour beaucoup dans un état
déplorable l'europe devait financer la
réhabilitation de ces centres ou en
étoile au point sans rien a commencé
l'europe devrait financer la
construction de centres de rétention
ligne de ce nom pour l'instant dans la
zone des grosses il n'en existe qu'un
qu'on a pu voir un reportage
les autres sont des casernes reconverti
mais pour l'instant rien n'est sorti de
terre en revanche l'administration
grecque a fait un effort pour essayer de
vider ses centres en libérant notamment
de nombreux marocains et algériens
mais il reste surpeuplé autre sujet de
polémique c'est ce mur que la grèce soit
érigé pour protéger sa frontière où en
est-on de sa construction
pour l'instant rien n'est sorti on se
doute que en grèce l'économie va mal et
que les investissements plusieurs gens
que cette clôture
mais avant même qu'elle ne sorte de
terre beaucoup doutent déjà de son
utilité puisqu'on l'a vu le problème se
déplacer les candidats sont prêts à
traverser la rivière ou à passer par
d'autres
d'autres endroits pour arriver en grèce
merci thomas
comme vous le voyez l'europe a quelques
difficultés à surveiller et contrôler
ses frontières extérieures à l'instar de
la grèce la moldavie connaît quelques
difficultés avec son voisin roumain
m'arrive
emoa été enquêté sur place alors marie
la moldavie c'est un petit pays de 4
millions d'habitants qui n'est même pas
dans l'union européenne pourquoi vous y
êtes vous intéressé j'avais entendu
parler de mouvements migratoires massifs
de moldaves vers l'union européenne vers
la roumanie
j'avais même lu un article qui disait
que la moldavie se vidait de sa
population j'ai donc voulu en savoir
plus sur ce phénomène et je me suis
rendu à kiss i know la capitale et dans
ses alentours
après cinq années passées en france
illégalement ce fait l'anah est de
retour dans sa moldavie natale pour
quelques semaines
elle est rentrée pour obtenir la
nationalité roumaine
une double citoyenneté facilitée par les
autorités moldaves et rue mène depuis
deux ans à 29 ans ces papiers vont lui
permettre de changer de vie en france
toujours aussi poitevine à cassel je
vais pouvoir rentrer librement à la
maison quand j'en aurais envie est
rentré en france comme n'importe quel
romain c'est la libre circulation et en
plus de ça j'espère que je vais pouvoir
voir un travail déclarés et trouver un
boulot un peu meilleures grâce à mes
papiers en règle déjà acté les
comme svetlana ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à demander la citoyenneté
roumaine aux moldaves ayant un parent ou
grand-parent d'origine roumaine est
éligible à la double nationalité soit
environ 65% de la population de ce petit
pays avant l'urss la moldavie
appartenait à la roumanie
preuve de cet engouement les files
d'attentes chaque matin devant
l'ambassade de roumanie racines sont
roux mais nous parlons romain si l'on
regarde l'histoire nous on est roumain
la superman c'est la délivrance de la
population de la république de meaux le
débit c'est la liberté
voilà c'est tout
la liberté de circuler dans l'union
européenne voilà le sésame qu'offre le
passeport roumain des agences à la
limite de la légalité ont fleuri dans le
quartier de l'ambassade
elle propose aux moldaves de leur
faciliter les démarches de raccourcir
les délais d'attentes face à l'afflux
des demandes
en effet on parle de plus de 800 mille
dossiers déposés depuis deux ans je
pense que la roumanie n'a jamais annoncé
publiquement officiellement par une voix
autorisée qui lie à eux sont 800 mille
dossiers en attente
pour moi ce chiffre est absolument
surprenant et je ne sais pas d'où ça
pour tout ça provient s'éteint c'est un
chiffre que je ne peux pas du tout
confirmé et que je trouve
personnellement largement exagéré et
plus dense et le président engouement
aux personnes qui annonçait ce chiffre à
la télévision publique en avril 2009
si la diplomatie roumaine aujourd'hui
tentent de minimiser le phénomène c'est
pour ne pas effrayer l'union européenne
à la veille d'une entrée probable dans
l'espace schengen mais aussi parce qu'au
sein même de la classe politique moldave
la question divise
si la coalition au pouvoir laisse faire
le parti communiste majoritaire voit ça
d'un mauvais oeil ce que sont en train
de faire les autorités moldaves ce n'est
pas un processus d'intégration dans
l'union européenne
c'est un processus d'intégration et de
la moldavie dans la roumaine
conséquence les multiples départs les
villages et les campagnes sont désertés
par la jeunesse partie travailler en
europe dans l'espoir d'une vie meilleure
le prêtre de nouveau de 3000 âmes à 30
km de la capitale assiste impuissant au
vieillissement du village et à la baisse
de fréquentation de son église
et
ça m'a piqué même si des fois tu m'as la
seule chose que l'on peut faire pour eux
c'est de prier
une fois par an on fait une prière pour
tous ceux qui sont loin de leur maison
en voyage et pour tous ceux qui sont
restés qui vivent dans le monde
je voudrais chien car les ordres à
sacramento le montre l'absence nicolaï
et léna le ressenti gouvernements de
chaque jour il ya des assiettes pour
tout le monde oui eux qui aime ton
recevoir et être entouré se retrouvent
aujourd'hui sans leurs trois enfants
valentin marchena et dan ont obtenu
leurs papiers roumains ils sont partis
travailler en france ou en italie
nous on espérait que nos enfants
étudient à l'étranger et qu'il
reviendrait ici
stockton évidemment qu'il deviendrait
ensuite fonctionnaires en moldavie et
puis qu on serait tous ensemble un faux
couple construite au cas où on a
construit une maison encore plus grande
qu'une école et aujourd'hui on est seul
obama single mon poids que je ne peux
pas être fâché contre eux a rappelé que
moi j'espérais que nos autorités fassent
quelque chose qu'elle prenne des mesures
pour que toute la population ne migrent
pas les gens partent par nécessité pas
de bon coeur il est clair que des
niveaux et nos des bons envoyés
nombreux sont ceux qui fuit le pays le
plus pauvre d'europe avant tout pour des
raisons économiques
ici le salaire moyen est de 150 euros
selon la banque mondiale 770 me moldavie
à l'étranger soit 20% de la population
marie quelle est la stratégie de la
roumanie dans cette histoire elle est
compliquée à saisir la stratégie la
roumanie parce que ce pays ne joue pas
cartes sur table pour des raisons
diplomatiques et politiques mais on peut
estimer que c'est avant tout pour des
raisons historiques la moldavie jusqu'au
début du 20e siècle faisait partie de la
roumanie a donc les liens historiques et
culturels très fort entre ces deux pays
pour la roumanie c'est un cette double
nationalité qui est offerte aux moldaves
c'est un moyen d'étendre son influence
est de convaincre l'union européenne
d'intégrer à moyen terme
la moldavie donc en fait ce n'est pas un
strict problème entre la moldavie et la
roumanie nom est d'autant plus que la
moldavie est un pays enclavé coincé
entre l'europe et la russie
la moldavie durant la majeure partie du
xxème siècle faisait partie intégrante
du bloc soviétique c'était la cave de
l'urss 30% circulation corps aujourd'hui
et russophone la russie cherche à garder
elle aussi son influence sur ce petit
pays
donc il ya une espèce de combat entre
l'europe et la russie pour acquis
gardera ce petit pays et c'est un peu
relents de guerre froide donc un rôle en
guerre froide à suivre merci marie au
delà de l'immigration un autre sujet a
longuement occupé les européens ces
derniers mois celui de l'énergie et de
l'énergie nucléaire en particulier
flora sauvage va nous en parler
donc flora 11 mars 2011 le japon est
touchée par un tremblement de terre
suivi d'un tsunami qui provoquent une
catastrophe nucléaire sans précédent à
la centrale de fukushima là le monde
entier c'est mieux on se souvient 25 ans
après tchernobyl que le nucléaire peut
être dangereux l'allemagne décide donc
de sortir du nucléaire d'ici 2020 et
provoque une polémique sans précédent
entre les capitales européennes ont
effectivement il n'y a pas de politique
énergétique au niveau européen
donc chacun des points de vue très
différents d'un pays à l'autre et on a
vu donc la suisse l'allemagne l'italie
sortir du nucléaire alors que la france
elle reste dans le nucléaire et vous
vous êtes donc aller en allemagne pour
voir comment est ce qu'il comptait en
sortir tout à fait j'ai notamment tourné
dans une ancienne centrale qui est au
nord de düsseldorf à kalkar qui a été
transformé en parc d'attractions dont je
vous laisse découvrir
bienvenue au pays des merveilles de
kalkar c'est le nom de ce parc
d'attractions ici les enfants jouent à
cache-cache dans cette ancienne centrale
nucléaire
elle accueille cinq cent mille visiteurs
par an dans ces hôtels bars et
restaurants comme nous l'expliquent le
directeur des lieux beaucoup de gens
étaient opposés au projet de centrale du
coup dont la construction a pris du
retard
la centrale a finalement été terminés en
1985 mais l'opinion publique était
déterminé à empêcher la mise en activité
de la centrale
un autre événement c'était tchernobyl il
ya eu un accident dans la centrale du
coup le projet de quelqu'un ça définit
clairement à risque
les allemands sont généralement hostile
au nucléaire la catastrophe de fukushima
au japon a renforcé ce sentiment à l'
agence pour l'énergie on connaît bien
cette tendance de l'opinion
la plupart des gens ont compris
après fukushima que l'énergie nucléaire
qui a beaucoup de dégâts même si on ne
peut pas les voir où les sentir je crois
que la majeure partie des gens veut
sortir du nucléaire
ici en rhénanie du nord on essaie depuis
longtemps de développer des alternatives
au nucléaire
car ce land le plus industrialisé
d'allemagne à des besoins énergétiques
considérables pour le moment le charbon
et le gaz représentent les meilleures
alternatives peut-être pas les plus
écologiques
mais elles sont comme est moins
dangereuse que l'énergie nucléaire en
rhénanie du nord il y a une ressource
importante c'est le lean it un charbon
composé de carbone
c'est l'une des principales richesses de
la région ce land axe ses activités
autour de cette ressource une industrie
pourtant très polluante
cet homme participe à la construction de
la nouvelle centrale à charbon de
nouilles rate qui entrera en activité
dans quelques mois tout le lignite
produit dans la région assure 30% de la
consommation électrique du pays du monde
aujourd'hui de nombreux centrales à
charbon pourrait être remplacé car leur
durée de vie arrive à son terme et elle
devrait être plus respectueuse de
l'environnement
le remplacement par cette technologie
nouvelle signifie pour cette région une
économie de 9 millions de tonnes de co2
développer des énergies plus vertes
c'est le créneau de monica écologiste
convaincue elle dirige une petite
entreprise spécialisée dans l'éolien
son but sortir du nucléaire par le biais
d'un bouquet énergétique
privilégiant les énergies renouvelables
pour sortir du nucléaire la stratégie de
l'allemagne c'est de mettre en place un
mix énergétique
nous avons 20 % nucléaire et les 80 %
qui restent
ce sont du charbon du gaz et des
énergies renouvelables
mais on peut arriver à 100% sans
nucléaire
un objectif ambitieux mais les allemands
sont conscients des limites de cette
politique
si l'allemagne veut sortir du nucléaire
et pas les pays bas je ne pense pas que
ce sera d'une grande efficacité
donc je pense qu'il faut soit ce que
tout le monde arrête le nucléaire
quoique personne n'arrête
jusqu'à présent en europe l'allemagne
est en pointe sur les énergies
renouvelables
des efforts qui resteront vains si ses
voisins ne jouent pas le jeu
donc laurent on l'a vu dans votre
reportage en fait ya de véritables
enjeux économiques autour de la question
des énergies renouvelables tout à fait
notamment en termes de création
d'emplois on sait qu'en allemagne les
énergies renouvelables représentent 250
mille emplois en france cela pourrait
représenter jusqu'à cinq cent mille
emplois donc ce n'est absolument pas
négligeable d'autre part les énergies
renouvelables représentent un atout
majeur en termes de recherche et
développement également mais est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un problème quand même de
repartir vers le charbon vers des
centrales à charbon quand il s'agit de
sortir du nucléaire et de favoriser les
énergies renouvelables
oui effectivement alors l'allemagne à
une ressource très importante et le
charbon elle la met en valeur elle
construit de nouvelles centrales pour
autant c'est une ressource qui est assez
toxique assez polluantes et qui est un
gros problème également c'est que un
jour il pourrait y avoir une pénurie
puisque y aura pas du charbon est un
allemand donc en fait le charbon ce
n'est pas forcément une très bonne
solution pour sortir du nucléaire et
favoriser les énergies renouvelables
c'est pas forcément une solution très
écologique en tout cas merci flora comme
vous le voyez la question du
développement durable et des énergies
intéresse particulièrement les
politiques européens
un autre dossier les a particulièrement
alerté la surmortalité des abeilles
fabriquent une assiette intéressé et a
même donné de sa personne
alors nous voici dans le rucher du
jardin du luxembourg c'est le plus grand
de paris et surtout le plus ancien il a
été créé en 1856 ici régulièrement des
auditeurs sont reçus pour se former aux
techniques d'apiculture et l'année
dernière le récolte de plus d'une tonne
s'est vendu en quatre heures alors vous
fabrice pourquoi est ce que vous vous
êtes intéressé à la question des
abeilles et de leur surmortalité
il ya clairement depuis plusieurs années
on dire depuis 2007 2008 beaucoup de
d'experts de scientifiques qui tirent le
signal d'alarmé le problème est beaucoup
plus complexe qu'il n'y paraît et c'est
ce qu'on a essayé de montrer de
découvrir dans ce reportage
allons voir comment travaillent les
colonies contrôle de routine cet
après-midi pour rita française qui nie
cette apicultrice installé ses 70 ruches
sur sa propriété de la région de rome
voilà treize ans sa fierté avoir le
label biologique
je vais aller vérifier s'il est sain que
j'ai mis ce matin est bien rentré dans
la ruche malgré toutes ces précautions
rita connaît depuis quelques années une
série d'épidémie aux effets désastreux
malheureusement oui
les infections ça existe il ya quelques
années j'ai perdu une vingtaine de
ruches à cause du var ont cette année
encore fin septembre j'ai perdu
plusieurs ruches
toujours à cause de ce parasite au
printemps cette fois c'étaient des cas
de lock européenne et de loque
américaine à l'image de rita tous les
apiculteurs de la région seraient
confrontés à ces problèmes
la faute à un acarien baptisé varroa à
des maladies ou aux pesticides
pire ces facteurs peuvent se cumuler
pour des scénarios d'épidémie complexe
fini les contrôles tout va bien
aujourd'hui tout va bien mais à chaque
épidémie souvent les mêmes responsables
montré du doigt l'agriculture intensive
et ses conséquences sur l'environnement
et dans certains cas l'apiculture
intensive qui affaiblirait les abeilles
bien sûr je suis préoccupé mais si nous
on agit on peut les aider à ne pas
disparaître mais il faut agir dans leur
intérêt pas dans le nôtre non et non
direction le front de mer à quelques
kilomètres de rome dans cet hôtel
les principaux responsables du monde
apicole sont réunis pour un colloque de
deux jours
vivienne de dautriche des états unis de
vlg
tous font partie du réseau apimondia qui
revendique 7 millions d'apiculteurs à
travers le monde et partout le constat
est alarmant
aujourd'hui l'intervalle entre chaque
surmortalité se réduit par exemple en
europe centrale en 2002 on a perdu
autour de 40% des colonies et en espagne
en 2005 on a atteint 50 % de pertes
bref c'est vraiment devenu un problème
mondial au moins un tiers de notre
alimentation dépend du travail de
pollinisation des abeilles et leur
affaiblissement récents pourraient avoir
de graves conséquences s'il se
confirmait preuve que la menace est
prise très au sérieux
l'union européenne a lancé un vaste plan
de sauvegarde des abeilles
pièce maîtresse du dispositif ce
laboratoire français près de nice et son
rucher expérimental on a besoin de
beaucoup d'abeilles pour nos essais pour
nos analyses on s'en sert comme abeilles
témoins sans pesticides sans maladie
pour justement leur maître ou les
pesticides ou des maladies et voir leur
évolution
au total quarante facteurs sont
identifiés pour expliquer
l'affaiblissement des colonies
d'abeilles un des rôles du laboratoire
analyser les échantillons qu'il reçoit
et identifier les causes probables de
mortalité du simple virus à l'action des
pesticides
voilà du pain d'abeilles qui a été
extrait des cadres des rayons est donc
là on va rechercher et résidus toxiques
en particulier les néonicotinoïdes qui
sont dans le poggio et le thiaméthoxam
des produits de traitement
phytosanitaire qui pose problème
actuellement
jean-paul faut qu'on le sait chaque
résultat incriminant des pesticides sera
contestée par les fabricants dans le cas
d'une maladie ou d'un parasite
la procédure est alors beaucoup plus
simple on fait un diagnostic et ensuite
les directions des services vétérinaires
prennent les mesures nécessaires pour
arrêter le phénomène arrêter la maladie
encore faut-il que les traitements
existent car si la filière tentent de
s'organiser face à la menace elle manque
aussi de réponse face aux maladies et il
serait beaucoup question de rentabilité
pour les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
globalement le marché des avait si on
peut s'exprimer ainsi n'est pas
suffisant pour un retour
d'investissement auprès des industriels
ce qui fait qu'il n'ya pas un
investissement de la recherche
industrielle pour mettre au point ces
molécules
ce qui fait que les apiculteurs sont
très désarmer la prise de conscience des
responsables politiques est récente du
recensement précis des ruchers un réseau
d'épidémiosurveillance tout est à faire
l'enjeu est de taille ne pas voir
certains scénarios catastrophes se
réaliser
et
donc fabrice on le voit dans votre
reportage il semble compliqué en fait de
déterminer les raisons de la
surmortalité des abeilles mais parce que
souvent ces raisons ce cumul il ya des
maladies ce qu'on appelle les pestes où
les loques
il ya le varois à la fameuse petite
petit parasite mais tout peut se cumuler
pour affaiblir la bei et donc la rendre
plus vulnérables à des maladies à ces
parasites
donc c'est difficile de clairement
identifier deux clairement dire qui est
responsable de quoi
par exemple dans les pesticides c'est un
enjeu un vrai enjeu parce qu'on les
écologistes et said d'interdire certains
pesticides en faisant valoir qu'ils
tuent les abeilles mais c'est difficile
de déterminer le degré exact de leurs
interventions dans la surmortalité des
abeilles et on parle souvent aussi de
l'agriculture intensive et de la
monoculture est-ce que ça rentre dans
les raisons ci si les abeilles sont en
présence seulement de colza par exemple
c'est comme pour nous si on boit que du
lait au bout de quelques jours on va pas
être bien pour la bei c'est pareil
mais quand on parle d'agriculture
intensif aussi parlé d' happy culture
intensive les deux les deux sont aussi
un danger pour la bei parce que certains
apiculteurs ont des pratiques qui
affaiblissent abeilles et l'union
européenne a décidé en fait de mettre en
place plusieurs plans
dans quel but alors l'idée clairement
c'est que il ya un constat une vraie
prise de conscience
les budgets ont été augmenté de 25 %
pour passer aux alentours de 30 millions
pour aider les pays européens dans leur
recherche est donc dans la recherche de
traitements aussi et surtout créer un
maillage un réseau et pouvoir confronter
les résultats d'avoir une réponse plus
générale est plus appropriée aux
différents types de problèmes qu'on
rencontre
merci fabrice voilà c'est fini
c'est la fin de notre émission merci à
philippe ricard et à la société centrale
d'aviculture de nous avoir reçu au
milieu d'eux se ruent chez nous on se
retrouve dans quelques mois
et en attendant sur publicsenat.fr pour
revoir cette émission
à bientôt
si tu veux bien